I had actually booked another role on a
film called Godzilla and it was like a
major role. It would have been a huge
break and I had booked a lead role on a
show called Divergent, which was like
going to pay me a lot of money. They had
my um my rights on the 100. They had to
approve me to be released to do these
other jobs and they didn't. They said,
"No, no, we need them. We don't know. We
don't want something to conflict." And
as soon as they did that, those other
jobs fired me. And then they fired me.
And so I was like, "So they got me to
work on the Sabbath. It cut out my other
jobs that would have been financially
life-changing. And that was when I first
got the understanding of how Hollywood
works. I was like, "Oh, they don't care
about you at all."
Welcome to Leed Live. It's a show where
we use the light of Christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today. And today we have Eli Gore with
us. Welcome to the LED live table.
Thank you guys for having me. I
appreciate it. We're in the presence of
somebody famous.
I just had to throw that out on the
table. No, it's a pleasure to meet you.
I've I've actually heard your name a few
times in the circles of what we do, you
know, so it's awesome to officially have
you on our show.
Really nice to meet you guys, too. I've,
you know, seen your guys' ministry. I
really appreciate the work you do.
Awesome. So, for those who don't know,
Eli is a former actor who's worked on
shows like Riverdale and the 100 and
played Muhammad Ali in One Night in
Miami directed by Regina King. But we
met in church. But I'm not going to
share too much of your story. I'll let
you do that. Uh but before we begin, I'd
actually like to share with our viewers
that we launched a YouTube channel
called Little Light Kids. There you can
find wholesome content exclusively for
children, teaching them good values, um
helping them learn about God's creation,
and also showing them how to strengthen
their walk with Christ in fun, creative
ways. You can find us on YouTube by
searching Little Light Kids or click on
the link in the description of this
video. Please go check out Little Light
Kids and share it with the children in
your life to enjoy and to make sure make
sure you subscribe so you can see when
new videos are posted. Eli, take us back
to the beginning like where are you from
and also what sparked your interest in
what became your career path? Um, so I'm
originally from a small city in uh in
Canada, Halifax, Nova Scotia. And um my
I guess what sparked my interest, what
first sparked my interest was uh I was
not raised in the church at all. And I
and I was a big Michael Jackson fan when
I was a little kid. I mean, I
I really wanted to be Michael Jackson.
That was like my ambition. And I just
thought there was something the fact
that he was a little kid and and then he
grew up and he was like doing all this
stuff and it was so enticing and it
always seemed like he had kids around
like you know and it just seemed like
you know so interesting to me. And so
that was like my first thing I remember
my mom saying that I would just
just sing and dance and sing and dance
and try to be like Michael Jackson for
hours. She would just put me in the room
and
can you do Michael Jackson?
Not I won't now but there was a time
when I had worked on it quite a bit. But
um so that was like the first initial
thing that I remember as a kid just
really being into cartoons, really being
into Michael Jackson. My older brothers
and sisters are always listening to
music in the house and so I was really
into like just entertainment as just as
a consumer of entertainment at a very
young age. And then um my mom was uh was
a mature student and uh she was doing
her degree and when I was young and and
there would often be because Halifax is
kind of a university town. There's St.
St. Mary's University, Dowhauser
University, Mount uh how is it Mount
Anyway, there's there's like four or
five pretty large universities
and um and so there would always be
interesting people and it's also kind of
a port city so there's just like always
a lot of different types of people,
musicians, artists, different educators
and um and so she was having a a get
together at the house and uh some people
were there that were young producers for
uh the CBC which is like the BBC but
it's Canada's version. Okay. and um and
they were producing kids content,
interestingly enough, given your uh your
plug just now. Uh and they were doing
something for Sesame Park, which is our
Sesame Street. And um
and they saw me and I guess I don't know
if I did anything or what, but they, you
know, were talking to me and then they
asked my mom, you know, we're doing this
thing and we're looking for a kid who
can do singing and dancing and this and
that. Would Eli, you know, be able to do
it? And my mom was always kind of like
even at a young age, she kind of talked
to us almost like in a mature way. And
so she just was like, "Well, let him
decide kind of thing."
And I was like, you know, so into it and
so excited cuz I was like, "This is it.
This, you know, I'm going to be Michael
Jackson, you know." And uh Janet
Thompson was the producers's name. And
and she um
she asked and I said, "Yeah." And I was
like five. And then uh and then I you
know she brought me out and we shot
these scenes for Sesame Park and I would
sing and I would dance and do these
things and I think she won a couple of
producing awards for it and and I got
paid and as a young kid you know getting
thousands of dollars you're thinking oh
man like this is this is pretty you know
I didn't even know what that meant. You
know what I mean? I just knew like penny
candies I could buy like
lifetimes I can buy. And then my mom was
like, "No, you put it in the bank." But
um so so that was my introduction. And
then
from there I kind of had two tracks as a
young person. I kind of my brother was a
very very talented athlete. Um he, you
know, was an all Canadian. Uh he
actually went on to play professional
basketball in Europe for a little while.
And um and so I had always kind of
thought about being an athlete and you
know kind of following what he was doing
because he was like kind of the big man
on campus around town and stuff like
that. But then I was also on the side
always doing these kind of artistic
things. So, I would do uh you know there
was this place called the Center for Art
Tapes and I would make like you know
music videos for my friends or I would
um you know do drama classes or if there
was a local play I would be involved in
the plays for Black History Month or
just everything and anything and it just
kind of accumulated to the point where I
had quite a large portfolio at a pretty
young age for someone from that town of
things that I had done. And even, you
know, I was I was DJing and hosting a
radio show um in high school um that
was, you know, pretty popular around the
city and, you know, things like that.
So, um putting on live events. And so
when I finished high school, um you
know, I I had to face reality that I was
not as good at basketball as my brother
was, nor was I as tall or as athletic.
So, yeah. So, after high school, I was
kind of like, okay, what am I going to
do? Am I going to go to school? am I
going to, you know, basketball's not
going to really be a real thing. You
know, there's not a lot of stuff in
Halifax. And I end up calling um this is
how like how little I knew about the
industry. So, in Halifax,
uh there are there's only one casting
director.
Wow.
One in OC.
I know. You can't even like
Halifax, but is it like that small of a
No, I mean there's probably about
300,000 people, but it's just I don't
know why. there was just one casting
director. And so, um,
I, as little as I knew, I literally
picked up the phone, I looked up the
casting director, I called and I said,
"Hey, uh, my name's Eli. I'm looking for
a job." Uh, you know, I'm like thinking
like this is just like, you know,
calling McDonald's or something like
trying to get a job. She was like, "It
doesn't really work like that,
but I actually have something that I'm
casting for and you might be good for
it. Come in."
Um, and this was kind of my first
dramatic piece that I had done. Um, and
it was, you know, I think it was like
thug number two or something like that.
Like super stereotypical, super
ridiculous, but but for me it was a
great opportunity because it got me into
the union.
Um, and so I did that and then I was
like, "Okay, that's done.
What am I going to do now?" And
there's no question of where you went to
acting school.
No, I mean, they didn't even like I
didn't even have an agent or anything.
Like there was it was I literally called
like that would be crashing if you did
that in any other city, you know? like
it's super super fauxpaw which I've
actually also done and it didn't well
anyway but you know but yeah but it just
you know it just worked. So, um, so I
finished that gig, I got in the union,
and then I was like, I talked to my
sister who lived in Toronto at the time.
And so, the backstory on that is my
brother-in-law, my sister and my
brother-in-law had just got married and
he was doing a lot of uh, background
extra work around Toronto and she was
trying to get him out of that and get
him into other things. But he would
constantly like tell her that if he
could, you know, he had to get 280 days
of background in a year, which is very
hard to do.
Um, and if you could do that, then you
could get in the union. He's like, if I
could just get in the union,
you know, I'll be rolling in the jobs,
you know, like there's just so many
opportunities. People are always telling
me, you know, I would have a job if I
was just union, you know, like telling
her this to keep doing it, right? And so
when she finds out that I'm in the union
now, she's thinking like, "Oh, Eli's
like basically Denzel Washington. Like
if you just get, you know, so she's just
like, "Yeah, come to Toronto. Come live
with me. You're in the union. You know,
it's going to be fine. You're going to
be, you know, famous." So I was like,
you know, I didn't have anything going
and I I wanted to keep working um now
that I kind of made that choice to go in
the entertainment direction. And so I
was like, and I was making pretty good
money for, you know, my age and
for being a thug.
Yeah. Well, yeah. Well, well, even the
Street Sense gig, like I had an actual
contract and stuff like that. And so I
was like, I don't want to go to school.
I want to keep, you know, working and
making money.
So I went to Toronto and I actually got
an agent there uh through the same
person who had got me on the childhood
stuff. She knew someone in town and she
was living there at the time, too. And
so I got an agent. I'm there. I'm with
my living sleeping on my sister's couch
and you know I'm in the union and um and
I'm I don't get any work cuz I'm a not a
good actor. I'm a terrible actor. I've
never I had no skills. I had no
training. I never done anything like of
any repute, you know, just thug number
two and and hosting stuff. So, uh so I
didn't get no jobs. None. Zero. I don't
know my lines. I'm like the worst actor
ever.
You also don't feel the need to study
this out either.
No. And that's the thing. Like I'm just
like totally winging it and I'm I'm
living with a like I'm living with my
sister but I got a bunch of dude friends
that are there too and they're like one
of them's a model and one of them's a a
musician and so like we're all like just
kind of boopping around thinking we're
artists. Exactly. And so um so and my
and my agent is really bad. Like he's a
terrible agent. He's always on vacation.
Like he he's just like the worst agent.
And I like you know he God bless him but
he was not he was not good at his job.
And so we're both terrible. And so
there's no jobs being had. And uh I do
that for about a year. It felt like a
lot longer, but it's probably about a
year and a half. And then um I'm really
I'm like, "Okay, well, I don't want to
just keep wasting my time. I think I'm
going to go back to school and, you
know, give this whole thing up." Right
before I do that, I end up getting a
commercial that um it was like a PSA for
Ontario. I don't even think I had any
lines. I think I was just like a cook,
but they like close in on me, so like
technically it was an acting job. And
then um after I finished the commercial,
there was a a thing in the union where
if it gets translated to any other
language, you get to pay for that as if
you did a whole another commercial.
And it got translated into like every
language cuz Toronto is super
multicultural and it was like a PSA. So
I got like 10 times what I was supposed
to get on this commercial, which wasn't
supposed to be a big thing at all,
which ignited the flame again, like
which was like, yeah, I got keys to the
money. Well, yeah, I got a big chunk of
cash. And so what happened was I um I
had uh my dad is from Ghana and I didn't
I didn't grow up with him, but um I knew
I had family in Ghana and I had uh you
know always wanted to get in touch with
my African side of my family and I had a
friend who was going to Ghana and who
was going to be visiting for a while and
I now had this chunk of cash and I
didn't I was thinking about leaving the
business and I was like, "Hey, let me um
do you think I could go with you guys?
do you think I'd go with you to Ghana?
And I was like, I want to meet my
family, but I wouldn't do it on my own
and you know, and you got it already set
up. And she was like, yeah, yeah. So,
um, I just took the money and I just
decided, okay, I'm going to go to Ghana
for as long as the money lasts and then
I'm going to come home and then I'm
going to go to school. And the program
that I was going to do was the Kings
this when I came back, I was planning on
going to King's College and taking
what's called the foundational year
program.
And it still exists today. People can
Google it. It's out there. Kings College
Halifax foundational year program. And
it's basically you study all the major
writings of the foundational books of
western culture and civilization.
And so um it the reason I was going to
take it is because it it basically
counts as two years in one. And so I was
thinking since I took a year off, I'll
do this program. I'll catch right back
up and then I'll you know I didn't miss
a beat. And and I was like okay well
they they they put out the list before
you go into the program of the all the
books that they're going to cover. And I
was like, well, if I'm going to be in
Africa, I'm probably going to have a lot
of time just on my hands. I want to
read. Let me pick one of these books.
And I had actually already started
reading some of the books. I finished
the Iliad. I'd finished Homer. I'd
finished a few other ones. Read some of
the Shakespeare stuff. And I was like,
let me just find whatever the biggest
book is, and that way I can just knock
it off my list.
I guess the Bible's on that list, too.
There you go. And it was the Bible.
Okay. Really?
The biggest book in that list was the
Bible. And so that's how I I I didn't
even have a Bible. I had to go to my
mom. And a funny story, I've told it
before, was um when I was a kid, my mom
had this huge
family Bible.
Oh my goodness. Is this like
is it the one with Jesus's last supper
on the front?
No. No, it's like just like the goldish
like off-white color like kind of
leather bound and um hard though. And um
so anyway,
nice point.
We weren't like Yeah, but we weren't a
Christian family. She had gotten it as a
gift, but it was in the house and she
had once been in the faith and she had
left and praise God she's back in now.
But um I saw it when I was a kid and I
was like I just saw the big letters on
the front. I was like mom
who's Holly Bibble
and she was just like she was like oh no
my son like you know like but I had
that's how little I knew about anything
religious you know I had no idea. I just
thought it must be a really important
person cuz her name was in like big
print you know.
Um but no so I actually went back to my
mom and I was like hey mom do you still
got that that Bible? You know I knew it
was a Bible now I was an adult and I was
like do you still got that Bible? And
she was like yeah. I was like, I want to
take it with me to Africa. Um, and so I
went to Africa
with this big old family
giant family Bible and I like I had this
backpack that my sister had got me like
that was like a piece it was like
luggage backpack like it was a huge
backpack
and uh as like a gift for the trip
and so I was traveling around Ghana, you
know, and and
puts the gun out of the thing and says I
said we're closed and I'm like
so now I'm like oh my gosh where am I
Right. And I remember thinking in that
moment, even though I was the most alone
I'd ever been, I felt a presence. I
didn't feel alone. And as the sun
started coming up, I started to calm
down. And I said, "Oh man, I was
tripping."
And my auntie calls and she says, "Where
you are right now, I wouldn't go there
if the president of Ghana himself
escorted me. You you your life was like
a mist." And it just all came flooding
back on me like, whoa, okay, I made an
agreement. I made an agreement with God
and I have to follow through cuz he did.
He brought me through it.
So anyhow, I I went to Bkina Faso and it
was, you know, beautiful experience. But
I mostly what I got out of that was my
reading of the Bible changed and I got
through the Old Testament and I now
believed in God. Um, I didn't know if it
was because I'd only read the Old
Testament. I didn't know if it was
Islam. I didn't know if it was Jewish. I
didn't know if it was Christian. But I
was determined to find out.
And so when I got back to Canada, I also
had a new desire to continue to act. But
I said, you know what? I have a little
bit of time. I'm going to give myself 6
months, but I'm going to be really
serious about it. I'm actually going to
like try to get good at this thing and
put in the time.
Okay.
And um I started doing, you know, local
theater. I started doing uh short films,
student films, just anything I could to
get in front of a group and and
practice. And
this is back in Toronto.
Yeah. In Toronto again.
And um at the same time, I'm starting to
learn more, trying to find out about
God. So, I'm talking someone gave me a
Quran. I'm starting to talk to Muslims.
So, I met some Jewish guys. I met some
Sunday Christians. And um you know, I'm
just kind of just feeling around with
that. But um still reading the Bible,
you know, still trying to get to the end
of it. And I get start getting better at
acting. you know, I start getting pretty
good and and I actually meet a guy uh
Ryan Singh, you know, one of my mentors
at the time. And it's funny because he's
actually married to an Adventist, which
is so I had no idea what an Adventist
was and I didn't know she was one, but
now I know. Um, but anyhow, he's kind of
takes me under his wing and starts
teaching me the craft of acting, which
as I look back now, there's so much of
that that is
spiritualistic, if not spiritualism,
that I was learning. So, it's like
you're learning a craft, right? They
call it a craft. Well, what is craft?
You know,
the terminology all there
and and so, but at the time, I'm like,
man, I'm getting good at this. I'm
getting ability, you know, and and he's
teaching me. And I ended up getting on
this show called The Kink in My Hair,
which was a pretty good show and a a
dramatic show was a, you know, a great
break for me. And then I got another
show out of that show. One of the
directors hired me on to a show called
Soul.
Same manager.
So what happened was the day I booked
the kink in my hair, I fired my manager.
Yeah.
And he was not happy about it, but I
said, "Hey man, you know, you know, you
know, you know what's up. Like come on."
And he he was upset, but he was also
kind of like, "Yeah, I know." You know,
and so uh I I went across town and I
actually ended up
I Googled, you know, top agents in
Toronto. And um it was actually one of
the top agents in North America at the
time because he was representing Drake.
He was representing uh Chenet Grimes
from 90200. He was representing like a a
list of these Canadian artists that were
just blowing up, you know, at around
that time. And so, um, I went in and I
auditioned for him and he signed me and
and uh, you know, at that time I really
appreciated him because he showed me
really how to be more professional in
the business. But anyhow, um, Norbert
Abrams, great uh, Jewish guy, great nice
guy and just solid solid agent. Very
agenty.
Had pictures of swords behind his desk
and like a husky just like super like
think like yeah classic agent. But
anyway, um, so I got this other show
based on that first show called Soul,
which was about a gospel choir and I was
playing a tenor, a singer in the choir,
and it's, you know, the dynamics that go
on within a choir. But what happened in
that experience was um the producer of
the show, me and him were riding home
one day from set and you know now I'm
starting to like really have some
conflicts internally because I'm reading
the Bible. I believe in God and I know
I'm not living
in a godly way.
Okay.
I'm living very much outside of what the
Bible says.
So this is in your personal life
necessarily what Hollywood is asking you
to do.
Right. my personal life.
I think it's just a matter of you're
around so many other people that don't
share those same moral compasses, you
know, and so it's just kind of the
nature of the beast, it's like you're
you're just influenced by everyone else
around you.
Yeah.
It's easy to get sucked into that world.
Well, and also, you know, to be honest,
I think as a young man at that time, I'm
trying to do two things at once. I'm
trying to read the Bible and be what I'm
reading somewhat. I'm like, I believe
it's true and I believe God is real. But
then the other side of me is like I want
to be famous. I want to be the man. I
want to be a player. I want to be
everything that I think is cool
and that the world is telling you this
is the goal.
So, you know, Ellen White has this uh
great chapter called the two crowns
and one is like the worldly crown that
is has some glimmer and some shimmer to
it, but it also has degradation and is
not, you know, is tinged and the whole
world is fighting and killing and
clawing themselves to get that crown.
And then there's this other crown that
just a small group are trying to pursue.
And that crown is like the the crown
that is perfect and and pure and you
know and so anyhow that's a beautiful
thing if anyone ever looks into it. But
uh made me think a lot about the
situation of being in in that
environment. But
I'm in this car. We're heading back from
set
and um his name was Andy Marshall. Still
one of my mentors today. And I just said
to him, I said, "You know, I've been
reading the Bible. I know you're a
Christian." because he produced this
Christian show that I'm on. And uh it's
not it's a show about a church, but I
know he's a Christian cuz he wrote it
and produced it. And I said, "You know,
when I read the Bible, it says you're
supposed to go to church on Saturday."
I said, "Why do Christians, you're a
Christian, why do Christians go to
church on Sunday?"
And he says, "Well, my church doesn't go
to church on Sunday."
Oh, wow. Okay.
And and I was like, "Really?" And and
it's so funny cuz when we talk about it
now, I know that he was like, "Oh, this
young lost man is trying, you know, God
help me. Give me the words to like not
mess it up, you know, and me, I'm
thinking, this is great. I'm getting,
you know, this information I've been
looking for."
And he's like, "Yeah, I'll tell you
what. When we come back to Toronto, cuz
we were shooting out of town. We're
actually shooting in my hometown." Uh he
said, "I'll I'll pick you up. We'll go
to my church and you can check it out."
And I said, "Yeah, definitely." And that
was the first time I went to Kinesisa
Fellowship. That was the first time I
went to a 7th Day Adventist church. Mhm.
And uh and instantly I was like, "Yes,
this is what I've been reading."
Wow.
You know, and even now when I look back,
it's like, you know, it's funny how you
see things differently, you know, over
time and God continues to help you to
see things. But I just remember like
looking at the way people were carrying
themselves, the way people uh the things
that they talked about, um the way that
the things operated. I was like, "Yeah,
this this matches what I've been
reading." And so from then on, I was
like, "Okay, I'm going to attend." Now,
you know, I'll fast forward many years
now and several years, I'll say. And uh
well, I'll stop. I'll do a pit stop. I
go to Vancouver for a quick for a little
bit. And um and I am in at a church
there. Uh uh uh Richmond 7th Day
Adventist Church with Elder Bill Wong.
Excellent church. Exc people. Good
people. Good. Good people. Um didn't
know how good they were at the time, but
they're good people. and a brother there
named Israel, a Jewish guy who had been
converted. These names right Emanuel
Israel of like the people but um
he gave me some DVDs of Walter
B
and this was so this was like
man it was a while back and so he gives
me the DVDs I go home I check them out
and I'm like
whoa
what is this
which series was it was
he gave me total onslaught
total on sale yeah
so I watch a little bit of it but I'm
like this is at the time I'm like this
is crazy talk this is crazy talk this is
never going to happen. So I go back I'm
like thanks bro. No I'm good.
That's so funny cuz he he's got some
pretty solid evidence of what he's
presenting.
So so there might be a lot of people
that don't know who Walter is that that
maybe watch our channel. Bless him.
So he was an atheist um professor from a
college university that taught evolution
in South Africa.
In South Africa. and and he actually
ended up studying the Bible to try to
prove it was wrong and proved himself
into the faith. And uh now he just he
just has a really beautiful series um
that goes over world events and shows
kind of this connection to like where
end time events meets the Bible meets
like you know things that are going on
in the world today. And actually that
guy is the one that woke me up, woke my
brother up. So, I know we share that in
common and it's like, you know, I
remember popping in that that whole
Total Onslaught series and it's like the
wool just went off my eyes and I just
was like, whoa, I can see what have I
been doing, you know?
Yes. Exactly. Well, and I think, you
know, you grew up in a in a Seven Day
Adventist home. I didn't and I'd been
going to the church, but there's there's
a lot of not not so much at Richmond,
but at other at other churches, there's
as many people that'll tell you, you
know, you have to really dig in and go
deeper as there are people that'll say,
"Don't worry about it. You know, you're
you're doing good, young man." In fact,
will encourage you,
yo, you're having success in this acting
thing. Go go, you know, good on you.
You're a real Adventist. So, it's like
you get these mixed messages. And so
although I wasn't getting that at at at
Richmond, but at this point I you know I
was kind of cemented in my nominal
Christianity. You know, I can live my
own life outside of church and then I go
to church on Saturday and I read my
Bible and I and I pray and really
separate them because in my mind I never
even saw the hypocrisy,
you know, I just
Wait, so you were never challenged on
that in terms of like was there a gig
that conflicted with Sabbath and you had
to like
Not at that point I wasn't challenged on
it. Um, but I'll come to that in a
minute. So, now I'm in LA and this is
when I, you know, I booked the 100 and
this is when I first had my experience
of challenging with the Sabbath. So, I
uh I get on this show. It's a big show.
Um, and I'm one of the main characters
and I try as I'm negotiating my contract
because how it works is you get tested.
So you don't actually you go up against
three other guys, you negotiate your
contract first, then you get to audition
for the final role.
So it's a very smart way for them to do
it because they have a lot of leverage
on your first contract.
So
because you don't have it yet.
Cuz you don't have it yet.
So you're willing to sign whatever.
Exactly. You just want to get the job.
So I um I tried to say to my managers
and my agents, I said, "Listen, um you
know, I'm a Seventh Day Adventist." At
this time, Devon Franklin was like
blowing up everywhere because
which can we just explain for the
viewers who he is?
Devon Franklin um how would I explain
him? He is someone that promoted Keeping
the Sabbath as a as an entertainment
mogul and also um you know has worked in
the heart of the entertainment world uh
working for people like Will Smith uh
working with Oprah Winfrey um but also
has maintained his Sabbath principles.
What path or religion are you?
I was raised 7th day Adventist.
Okay. And what does that mean?
7th Day Adventist is a Christian
denomination and one of the things that
we believe is observing the Sabbath. So,
Friday night sundown or Saturday night
sundown as mentioned in the ten
commandments. Remember the seventh day
to keep it holy. Uh and then also Jesus
uh observes Sabbath as well. Yeah.
So, it's one day
where I don't check my emails.
I don't respond to work calls. I don't
read anything. Friday night
Friday night sundown
sundown
to Saturday night sundown.
Yeah.
No work.
You don't check your emails.
No.
There's a function.
That's that's like against the
commandment of Hollywood that thou shalt
carry thy blackberry at all times.
But you know what? Here's a good thing.
When you set boundaries.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Up front.
Here's what my commitment is. So we all
agree
before we even take the job or go down
the road.
Here's the commitment.
Yeah.
Are we all agreeing this is okay? Mhm.
So then all I have to do is just make
sure I keep the commitment
because the moment I break it,
yes,
is the moment they realize, oh well, he
wasn't that serious.
But for me, Sabbath is a time to
recharge. It's a time to rest. It's a
time to spend time with my family. Uh
it's a time to spiritually reconnect. Um
it's incredible. If I embrace who I am,
Wow.
It will open doors, not shut them. Also,
if your faith
won't fit in the door that opens.
Yeah.
Then I argue, do not walk through that
door. the door that God has opened for
you will fit your faith.
He's a producer or director or both.
He he was an executive
first and then for Sony and then he also
was a producer and an actor.
Um and he also now does uh public
speaking. That's what he's and an
author. Very popular book, The Weight
with Megan Good, which was about you
know uh abstinence.
And that's his wife.
And that was his ex-wife. Okay. Um, so
and you know I met him and we have we're
pretty we know each other pretty well
and he's always been very very kind to
me. I you know I only say good things
about him.
Um
nevertheless uh so he was blowing up at
this time. We didn't know each other but
his story was everywhere
which helped your case
which helped which I used for my case.
Exactly. And I was showing them you know
this guy in Oprah. I said you know I
want to keep the Sabbath. And they came
back and they said well what we'll do is
we'll do best efforts. And I was like
what's best efforts? And they were like,
"Well, it means, you know, if everything
goes wrong, you might have to work a
Friday, go over a little bit, but we're
going to make, you know, really try to
make sure that you don't have to work."
And I was like, "That sounds
reasonable." I didn't know Hollywood
and I didn't know how they operate.
Get you to sign.
Yeah. Exactly. And so I said, "Yeah,
signed." First week I'm there, Friday,
Eli, uh, where you going? You know, you
have your shoot tonight. I'm like, "No,
no, it's a Sabbath. your best efforts
and they're like, "Uh, no, you're
definitely booked. We're doing an all
night shoot tonight.
You have your big speech tonight."
And it's this, you know, this all night
thing. There's this rain. There's a
fight scene and I give this, you know,
embellished this speech. Um,
and I was there till the next morning.
Literally on Friday night. And I was
like I was so tired I couldn't even go
to church. And it was crazy cuz we're
shooting in back in Vancouver. So, I'm
like, I'm back where I could actually go
to my my home, like my church that I'd
gone to. And um I want to just say this
quickly. I don't say this often, but um
Elder Bill Wong, I really appreciate him
before I left. He's the only person who
said, "Eli, LA is Sodom and Gomorrah,
and I don't think you should go."
And I and I really wish I'd listened to
him.
And I didn't. But I appreciate that he
said it because no one else said it. Um,
and you know, it takes courage to say
that to someone who, you know, when when
you know that they're not going to take
it well. Um, so I appreciate Elder Bill.
Anyhow, um, so I'm there. I have to work
all Sabbath. And from then after we shot
the pilot, I go back home
and bunch of things happened. I had
actually booked another role on a film
called Godzilla and it was like a major
role. It would have been a huge break.
And I had booked um a lead role on a
show called Divergent, which was like
going to pay me like
a lot of money, a bunch of money. And
you would have been one of the actors on
that.
I would have been one of the actor. I
booked it.
But um they had what's my they had my um
my rights on the 100. Can't remember the
term right now. First first rights. I
can't remember what it's called right
now. But anyway, they had to approve me
to be released to do these other jobs
and they didn't. They said, "No, no, we
need them. We don't know. We don't want
something to conflict."
And as soon as they did that, those
other jobs fired me.
And then they fired me. They didn't pick
up my option. They had my option. That's
the word. They have my option.
And so I was like, so they got me to
work on the Sabbath. They cut out my
other jobs that would have been life
financially life-changing. And then they
didn't even pick up my option.
And that was when I first got the
understanding of how Hollywood works. I
was like, "Oh, they don't care about you
at all.
It's to like they will totally
disrespect you." And so the next time I,
you know, I, you know, licked my wounds,
got back to it, and I got it, I tested
again for another show. I think it was
the maybe a year later. Um, one thing
that I learned about that business is
things go in cycles. And you might be
down once, but if you're consistent,
things will come around if you, you
know, because they they, you know, they
always need fresh fresh faces, fresh
people, fresh blood, uh, for lack of a
better term. Um, anyhow, so
uh, I got another opportunity. I tested
for a show that LeBron James was
producing, kind of
semi-autobiographical, Survivors
Remorse, and it wasn't a very good show.
I'm glad I didn't do it, but they I was
testing and the same thing happened. And
they were like I was like I keep the
Sabbath and they were like oh you know
we'll do best efforts. I said no no
sorry. I was like no no no none of that
this time. I know what that I know what
that means. I'm not doing it unless you
guys you know give me the Sabbath. And
they said well Eli you're going to lose
this show.
And I said okay well then I'm going to
lose the show but I'm not I'm not
testing. I'm not doing it because I knew
they wanted me and I knew the casting
director and uh I said I'm not doing it
unless uh unless you guys give me the
Sabbath. And they said well then you're
going to you're going to lose it. and I
gave it up. And that was the first time
I kind of stood on my squares, took, you
know, stood by my principles. I felt
better about that than I had felt about
what had happened before. And so, you
know, time went on and my career started
to gain momentum. Um, I did a movie
called Race. And I was always adamant
from that moment forward. From the very
beginning of the auditioning process,
guys, you I keep the Sabbath, so don't
let me get into a situation where this
is a conversation,
you know, and I started getting a little
bit more, you know, assertive cuz I was
like, cuz it's it's it's a hard wall.
I'm not doing anything if I can't do the
Sabbath. And they were like, we don't
know if you're ever going to work. I
said, well, then maybe I'll never work,
but I'm not breaking the Sabbath. And
so,
and again, I'm still not even living
right. I'm not living right, but I'm at
least knowing I want to keep that. That
is my principle. That's my line in the
sand. So, um, so then I got the I got
race and they they said, "Yeah, you can
do it and you you can keep the Sabbath."
And I was like, "Oh, so they respect you
more in this business if you set
boundaries than if you just let them
walk all over you." They actually want
you more. They act like it's going to be
a problem, but it's the more problems
you give. That's why you hear about
these diva actors because the more
boundaries you set, the more they
actually want. It's like this like we
want what we can't have kind of thing.
And so I did that movie and it was a
great learning experience. They actually
tried to get me to work. They sent a
Jewish guy to my door one Friday night
and was like, "I'm Jewish. I understand,
but brother." And I was like, "Brother,
you're Jewish. YOU SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
DON'T come here." He was like a top
producer or something. And and then uh
and then he said, "You're right. I'm
sorry." And he left.
I was like, "I hope that brother got
converted." But anyhow, um, so yeah, so
you know, things are still progressing.
I start I did Ballers and then I, you
know, and then I got Riverdale and then,
um, I I I got, uh, one night in Miami
and, you know, things are really
cooking. Like I'm like, you know, I'm
meeting with everybody. I'm meeting with
everybody, you know, uh, Stephen
Spielberg's companies and and Tyler
Perry and, you know, I have these people
on my phone and I'm like, this is kind
of crazy. I'm actually like I'm about to
be famous. Like this is crazy. You know,
my agents are like I'm signed with like
this company that I always wanted to
sign with which is William Morris
Endeavor. They were the top agency and
and you know my agent I remember her
telling me like I got nominated for a
Screen Actors Guild Award and she was
like Eli I just want you to know you'll
never you'll never be without work
again. She's like that's what that means
from getting that award
from that. Yeah. And I was like
what what do you mean? And she was like,
"I'll always it does I don't know what
level of fame you're going to have or
what success you're going to have, but
you'll I can always get you work now. I
can get you work on a TV movie. I can
get you work on a anything, you know."
So, after that movie, after One Night in
Miami, I was like I was like, "Okay."
Like I I finally felt like I could
breathe and all the work and all the
sacrifice and all the things that had
gone on throughout that time were kind
of paying off.
And how many years were you in LA doing
this uh
up until this point?
I'll hold that. I'll hold that.
Okay.
But but a while. A while.
It takes 10 is what I remember them
always saying like before you even
really start to figure it out, it's a
good 10 years.
That's an investment.
You want to get there.
I was there 10 and I took off.
Okay.
So, um I had heard different things. I'd
heard between six and 10, but yeah, it
takes a while. And um so, so yeah. So,
I'm there and things are taking off
and then CO hits literally like a few
weeks after. In fact, I think I got CO
when I was shooting one night in Miami
and didn't know it cuz the Marty Gro was
going on at the same time and all these
people were in the city and then I found
out later that they had a huge outbreak
on the news. So, I was like,
I think I had it cuz I got super sick
like one of my last days of shooting,
but we didn't know what it was. And it's
funny because my mother had been
emailing the family saying, "Guys,
something is coming. You guys got to get
ready." And we were like, "Mom, she's
she's always on YouTube. Shout out to
mom."
Yeah. Mom, listen to your mom,
man. She She was like, "Anyhow, but um
so you're saying you got the award and
then the world shut down." So, I got
nominated for a Screen Actors Guild
Award and No, no, I got the job and I
did the job and it was everyone knew it
was like a a blacklist script and it was
Virginia had just won the Oscar and she
was did it like it every it was
it was just the it was one of the movies
of the year
and so I my career was now in a
different place as a result of doing
that and I was hanging out with
different people and things were
different things were happening and then
COVID hit
and I'm still we're doing the promo and
we're doing all the nominations, we're
doing stuff but CO is happening and I
remember when I was sitting at home and
I was watching the news because of the
lockdowns and they showed Naomi Campbell
at LAX in a hazmat suit
and I said, "What is going on?" And then
almost I can't I think it was the same
night I just looked out my window and I
was I was on to Hunga Avenue in Studio
City and I just saw military truck,
military truck, military truck, military
truck
and it was like 12 12 of them and I was
like and something in my head clicked
and said that Walter V guy was right.
I said this is exactly what he said was
going to happen.
It's going to happen.
And I was like I couldn't even remember
his name actually. I just knew that who
he was from the videos and I went
searching for him
and I found his videos. I found Total
Onslaught
and I watched them all in like three
days. All 30 videos. I just
That is heavy.
Yeah. I watched them all. I was just
like, I need to know everything about
what's going on. And And it was now
it was the experience that you had where
it was like spiritual things are
spiritually discerned. The wool came up
over my eyes and I was like,
"Yeah, you see it.
Oh man, this is ex." And and now also
because when I had first gotten those
DVDs, I hadn't really been in LA. I was
still in Vancouver.
But now I'd had a career in LA and I had
met with these people and I had been
told offered to join sun worshipping
cults. I had been offered to join I had
seen people that were Freemasons and
seen how their success was. I had seen
uh Ben put in hotels that were voodoo
hotels and uh seen people make seances
on set and wear snake rings and I knew
that everything that he was saying I
knew it was true because I knew the
people I saw them do it every day. That
was my life
was operating in this environment and
thinking really not even thinking as
much as rationalizing oh I can be a
light in the darkness but I'm not a
light in the darkness because I'm living
crazy.
Yeah. You know, it's their system. And I
think you know, the good nature of of
you and you when you understand the
truth is I'm going to go in there and
I'll help share shed the light. But this
is a whole system of darkness that is
like not interested in spreading the
light.
Absolutely.
They're a little tiny pin drop in this
huge machine
and they know a lot of what we don't
think they know. It's not it's not,
you know, ignorant uh behavior. They
know it. You know, the same person who
offered to bring me into the Sun Cult
said, I told, he said, "What do you
believe?" I said, "Oh, I'm a Seventh Day
Adventist."
He said, "I used to be a Seventh Day
And I was like,
serious?
Oh, well, what do you believe? He's
like, well, uh, in all my studies, I've
determined that the only thing you can
truly worship is the sun.
And I was like,
uh, well, I was in his trailer and I was
like, okay, well, it's good talk. You
know, he was a big actor and, you know,
I wanted to be, you know, he said he
wanted to take me under his wing. He
said Denzel had brought Nate Parker
under his wing. He wanted to be bring me
under his wing. And I wanted that, but I
wasn't, you know, I wasn't going to be
in a some worshiping call. God had, I
guess, just given me certain boundaries.
And by his protection, as you said
earlier,
he just kept me from crossing them. And
um but as I was learning more, I felt
like God's expectations were getting
more and more and I started to see more
and more things as a problem that
weren't a problem before for me,
you know, and my personal life was still
not in alignment. My personal life was
still out of it. Even though I was
trying, when you have strongholds in
your life and when you're compromising
constantly, it's really hard to walk a
straight life when you're when you have
a a whole side of your life that is not
straight.
Absolutely. you know, you can't walk on
two sides of the street at the same
time. And so, um, so, but yeah, I watch
Walter Vice. I'm I see it all now. At
the exact same time that I'm finally in
my career where I've always wanted to
be. And so, in that moment, I'm like,
"Okay, I'm faced with a choice." And so,
I ended up getting another one more job.
And I kind of made that deal with God. I
was like, "Okay, God, I need to just let
me get this one job. Let me do one more
job. Get some money." And at this point,
I'm now watching Dr. O on on YouTube and
the state line 7 church the Sunday law
update and learning about you know the
Sunday law is coming and we should get
country land
in in California you're watching
I mean watching this from California
and so you know I'm like God I need
countryland I need money for country
land let me do one more job
interesting justification yeah
and I'll get country land and so
which never works out because all of
that is relying on your own strength and
God is like I don't work that way
exactly and so I did this job I ended up
you know doing one more job and it
The real payout was second season. The I
got a good chunk of money the first
season, but the second season was where
I was going to have like, you know, some
big money and I had a a movie deal that
was coming out and I had a podcast and a
bunch of things were kind of lined up
for one more year. And so then the
conversation became, okay, I got a
mortgage, but I was like,
one more season. And God was really
speaking to my heart like, no, no.
Wow.
No. And um I I I talked to my mom and I
said, "Mom, listen, like I'm one year
away from like making enough money like
you don't have to work again, you know,
and and uh I can, you know, do a lot of
different things." And um but I need to
do, you know, I need to finish a couple
jobs. But I told her, you know, I was on
this show and it was a very uh satanic
show. It was produced by Jesuits
and uh you know there was a lot of
scenes in there where even one scene
I'll give an uh one quick story is um
they were shooting a scene where they're
creating my body on a on a it's
basically they make it's a show about
you travel to the future and they give
you avatar bodies. Okay.
And so they're they're making my body on
this slab and they have all this
semi-biblical language that they're
using as they're making it and you know
he formed him out of the dust and all
this weird stuff in the script and
there's all kinds of like they're
showing left eyes all over the place.
like super, you know, crazy stuff.
And you're you know all this. You're
aware of all this. It's not just in post
like
No, I'm I see it in the script. And I'm
actually I even
see this is the thing, right? Like when
you want to be ignorant, you'll be
ignorant. Because I even messaged Walter
V and I was like, you see, I got this
script. I sent him screenshots of the
script. I said, you know, should I do
this? And he didn't get back to me. And
I was like, well, guess I should do it,
you know, as opposed to like the Bible
clearly says you already know. So why
would he you need to tell Walter Vice if
you know it? It's like Balum, you know.
Exactly. Like Baum, you know, but you're
going to try to find, okay, God, may
maybe there's a a good outcome that can
come out.
Exactly. Ex. And you know, looking for
the donkey to tell you, you know, and so
um so anyway, I'm on this slab and
they're shooting and they got the camera
over me. And as they're doing it,
they're saying like, "My face is going
to be created from this side to this
side." And I already know they're going
to cut off half my face so that just one
of my eyes is showing
and and I'm like, "I don't want that. I
don't want to be on camera like that,
you know. And so, especially I've
watched Walter Vith, I know these guys
are Jesuits. They told me they're
Jesuits. They sat down with me and they
said, "We're Jesuits."
And I was like, "This is crazy." And so,
um, and so I'm like, "I don't want
that." So, I closed my eyes. I'm like,
"If I close my eyes, then they can't get
one eye open, right?"
And they said, the director's in the
back. He's like, "Open your eyes." And
I'm like, "No." And then he's like, he's
like, "We need to get the shot." And I'm
like, "No, because you know in the last
shot my eyes were closed. Plus, if
you're making my eyes, you got to make
my eyelids. So, my eyes would be closed.
And he's like, "Yeah, I guess that's
true." And then they go back and
but we still want to get it just in
case. Like,
no. And then, so I open my eyes and then
the next day they bring us in to see a
reel of the cuts that they've made so
far. The very last shot is them making
half my face with my one eye.
And I said, "I can never get that back.
I can never get that back.
People are always going to, you know
what I mean? It's it's alarming when you
when you actually look up on the
internet how many celebrities have been
photographed with only one eye or
covering one eye. I mean it's everybody
and it's like they can't just be doing
that just because I mean that's just so
random. How many pictures have you taken
like that, you know? It's like
but but there are there are people that
will I was in a photo shoot where
someone gave me an apple
said, "Yeah, we just want you to eat the
apple." And I was going to do it. I was
like, "Oh, yeah, cool. An apple." And I
was like, "Whoa, whoa. I see what you
guys are doing.
Follow instructions, but it's your image
out there, not theirs." Exact. And also
I only stopped because I know. But if I
didn't know, if I was just a young actor
doing a photo shoot, you're doing a
magazine, you're excited, they give you
an apple. Yeah, I'll eat the apple, eat
orange, whatever. You know,
so I did that and I know what's up. And
so I go to them and I'm like, listen, I
don't ever want that to come out. You
know, I gave a whole bunch of other
reasons. I didn't just say, hey, you
guys are a bunch of Jesuit and Masons
and I don't want, you know, your agenda.
But I gave a bunch of, you know, other
reasons. I said, you know, it's not
continuity for the other stuff and blah
blah blah. artistic integrity and they
agreed and they sent me an email and d
and it didn't come out I don't think on
the show but I know they have it and it
bothered me and so I told my mom that
and I and I said you know but I got I'm
trying to decide if I should do season
two and you know I said it's big money
and she said Eli you already know and
it's funny because I know you know the
money would have really helped and I was
expecting her to say yeah just do one
more season and then you know you'll be
good and that's like moms man there you
know Um, she was like, "Eli, it sounds
to me like you already know what you're
gonna get. And if you do that, you know
that there's going to be a cost."
Yep.
And so I don't see how you could do it.
And she said, "If you do it, you're
going to be a hypocrite cuz you're going
to tell all these other young people,
don't do this after you've gotten all
that money and that's why you left."
And it bothered me that she said that. I
was like, "Hypocrite. I didn't like
that." You know what I mean? I didn't
like that she said that. It bothered me.
Strong word. Yeah, it was a strong word.
But it was like, but I thought about it
and I was like, "Okay." Okay. And then I
was like, still I was praying and I went
to church the next day and I was in the
parking lot. I said, "God, okay, I'm
going to do this, but you need to you
need to make it crystal clear that this
is what I should do." And I literally
walked in and Dr. O was preaching and he
he's standing there and he goes,
"Something I don't know what's making me
say this,
but somebody in here needs to know. They
need to come out of Babylon." And he
goes on a full sermon
on Hollywood. He starts talking about
So Dr. O was in Alabama.
Dr. O was in Alabama. Yeah. So, at this
point, I moved. I bought my country
house, but I was on a mortgage, but I
got, you know, some land. Um, but he did
a full sermon on it about coming out of
Hollywood. And he didn't, it wasn't like
he saw like doing it for me. He just
said something came over me. And he's
like that. If you guys had ever, he's
like that.
And um
and I was like, "All right." So, that
day on the Sabbath, I I wrote an email
and I just messaged my whole team. I
said, "Listen, guys.
Uh, you know, I'm I'm retiring." M
and they were like they were surprised
because it's just a surprising thing,
but they said it made sense with who
they knew me to be and that they could
see there was always a struggle since
the Sabbath stuff.
So an email was enough. How hard was it
to get out of that?
Uh it was enough. It was enough. I think
because people knew me, but I think that
the
No, I'm talking contract.
Oh, well that was the other thing,
right? So, I was under contract for that
show, which is why like I had a whole,
like I said, I had a movie deal and a
bunch of other things, but I had to do
the show cuz again, they had my option.
So, they were going to let me do all
that other stuff this time, but I had to
do the show.
And I was like, the only way out, the
only way I can I can move forward is to
retire.
Oh, wow.
Wait, so you can retire and then you
avoid problems with the contract?
Yeah, you can always retire.
Anyone can retire, right? Like if I'm a
boxer and I have a boxing contract,
you lose everything and you lose the
trust of the industry, right? Because
you know Michael Jordan can retire and
come back. Well, yeah, you're going to
take him back. But, you know, if someone
else on that team other than not named
Michael Jordan had done what he did,
they would be like, "No, buddy."
Yeah. So, if like Brad retired and came
back, yeah, sure.
Yeah, exactly. We'll take Brad Pitt. He
can retire 10 times. But, you know,
which is what what's the football player
did?
Uh Ricky Williams.
No, no, no. The one who was married to a
witch.
The the goat.
Oh, yeah. He retired like three times.
Tom Brady.
Oh, Tom Brady. Yeah, exactly. They'll
always take Tom back, right? But there's
other a lot of other football players
who will retire for good reasons and
they won't take him back. Even though
they can Colin Kaepernick,
right? They'll never let Colin play.
Colin's a great player, and I'm not a
promoter of sports, but he's very
talented.
Um, but they'll never let him play
because it's it sets a precedent. No,
you can't just come and go,
you know, but certain people they can
and certain can't. But anyhow,
um, you know, they offered me even until
recently, they offered me a lot of
roles. And Eli, are you sure? Are you
sure? But you know I'm sure.
So you retired when?
So I retired just over a year ago.
Okay. And you know, I would say right
around COVID is when I really I started
to kind of face those demons of living
once I started to read Adventist Home
and it showed me what, you know, what
real manhood was about and I started to
really kind of look at where my life was
at and the kind of things that I was
compromising on and um some other things
went on and I was just like, you know
what, it's time to make some changes and
and I did some serious prayers with some
people that I felt certain things break
off
and that I had been struggling with. And
um and from then, you know, I felt that
was another reason why I was ready to
walk away because I felt like I really
had a lot of power hol from the Holy
Spirit and victory in in my life to
really like live right
and I didn't want to be playing with
that,
you know? It's like okay. And so
so yeah, so I I messaged them and then
uh and then I retired. Yeah. But I mean
that that that's got to that's got to
really also be you know where your head
space is at with like you know the
truth. There's a good reason so your
mind isn't going to constantly playing
games with you like I what what my life
would have been like if I would have
done this or that. It's like no we're at
the end of this war and you can see it
in front of you and yeah I think
compromise seems to be the key. You see
a lot of actors, I mean their lives
generally, um, there's probably ones
that can steer clear of like the real
messy lives, but mo most of the real
successful people, if you could dive
into their personal life, there's a lot
of compromise that happens and they get
themselves in a lot of trouble. And so
it I I kind of felt like that way, too.
When you read the Bible, you really
understand the principles that are
there. It's really hard to rectify those
two worlds together. They just don't
seem like they line up at all.
Yeah. It's impossible. you you know
you'd have to be you can only do it when
you're in ignorance
because the Bible says you know come out
of her my people and so
there's once you understand that this is
Babylon and this is like the the the
mouthpiece of Babylon
this is the agenda speaking message
creating
entity of Babylon
and you are representing Christ who has
the exact opposite message but you're
allowing them to use you as their tool
to promote their message
so It's they're they're totally in
congruent.
Mhm.
Someone, you know, I don't even think
like,
you know, something like this where
you're doing an independent ministry or
where you're doing a a documentary or
something in that form, I think you can
serve the Lord with media. But as far as
doing scripted dramatic um
the types of entities that Hollywood has
created as the forms of how you deliver
content, those things are I mean even
when you look at the the um the networks
and the distributors
and the people that have to filter your
stuff to get it out to mass medias ma
mass audiences. It's totally controlled
by a an agenda that is going to try to
cause you to have at least have
compromise
and then even more so try to promote a a
ungodly agenda.
Yeah. What wasn't it um Sound of Freedom
was bought originally purchased with
from Disney
and they shelved it for like seven years
and you would think
Yeah. You would think like Disney has
always sold themselves as the
familyfriendly company, right? That's
their kind of like they tried to have
the squeaky clean look and it's like
wouldn't that company be interested in
protecting children?
I mean
it's the opposite.
Yeah. It's very interesting to me that
they became the um I think stopping
point for a while. I think there was a
big court battle to like wrestle that
back to where they could actually
release it.
And you know, I'll be honest with you,
even like I think everyone's at
different levels, but even a movie like
that, you know, I would look deeper into
it. And I know you guys have done
studies on Passions of the Christ and
you know movies that
for instance I'll just give examples
like there's a lot of people that talk
about like why couldn't you just be a
Christian actor right a lot of people
ask me that
but 90% of those Christian movies deal
with spiritualism right you know
someone's coming down from heaven
they're talking to their you know this
angel that was a dead person and is now
an angel and is helping them through
problems or you know uh near-death
experiences where they saw God and you
know miracles do happen and all this
kind of stuff which is totally
unbiblical.
Right.
Right. And so the idea like I have some
really close friends that are huge
producers in the Christian Christian
space.
Um but you know I can't work with them
because we have different I I have a
message that is the truth for this time
from from the book of revelation 14 uh 6
and 7. and they have a message that is
kind of a different message that's a
totally non,
you know, it's it's truth mix and error.
It's it's Bible mixed with tradition
and, you know, so those two things, um,
you know, I have to stand on my spot and
say what I know is right.
Absolutely.
I think you made the right choice. I
really do.
Um, every time I've been kind of near LA
and gone back there, there there is just
like an like you can feel there's
something different about that location.
Absolutely. And um you know people kind
of say well what is it like electricity
or they'll say like it's a energy or
whatever like that. I I think there's a
lot of demonic activity. Why wouldn't
there be? I mean if this is a if this is
a mouthpiece of information
I mean you think about people aren't
just walking into a satanic church,
right?
But they'll click on the TV.
But you're clicking on the TV. So the
devil has to get his information to the
people somehow. And it's like these are
his churches. These are his pastors.
These are his ways of sharing that
information with the world. Now, not
everybody recognizes that, but I do
think that the majority of it is not
upholding righteousness, holiness, godly
attributes that we know the Bible is
trying to teach and promote.
I mean, even on things like a like a
nature show, you know, when you watch
when you turn on Netflix and you're
like, "Oh, I know. I'll just watch
something totally non harmless. Let's
watch, you know, Lions of the Savannah."
The first thing you'll hear when you
turn it onion,
six million years ago, the lions roam
and it's like, no, that's not true. The
Bible says that the world is, you know,
not just over 6,000 years old and or
just around 6,000 years old, you know,
it's, you know, but so that's that stuff
affects people, right? They they as
you're a kid and you watch that, you
just assume that that's true. It's a
sermon
and you know like planet earth, one of
the most amazing cinematic pieces that
highlights this just awesome planet that
God made. No credit to him whatsoever.
There you go. And that's just the sad
reality of it. And it's like, you know,
I I just don't believe that it is as
easily,
you know,
able to promote a really wholesome,
righteous, you know, god-fearing
lifestyle. Uh I I think even in the
Christian space there's a lot of mixture
in those.
Absolutely.
Lot. Yeah.
Okay. So you sent that email saying that
you're retired. That was about a year a
year and a half ago.
Where are you today?
I've been spending a lot of time
obviously studying my Bible,
you know, reading Spirit of Prophecy. Uh
can we just explain for the viewers what
Spirit of Prophecy? What do we mean by
that?
Oh, absolutely. Uh so Alan White who um
was one of the founders of the 7th Day
Adventist Church and is uh a prophet I
believe based on what I've read and how
that lines up with the Bible and not
because of anything she said that's
nothing that she said is different than
what the Bible says. But it just allows
you to have a a commentary and an
understanding on a deeper level. Um and
so I've appreciated those writings
because they've helped me in my Bible
study. um which is always first and
foremost. Um but as I've studied those
things, it teaches about proper diet for
instance. Uh it teaches about um how to
be a better son, how to be a better man,
how to be a better member of your
church, uh a better member of your
community. Um the types of uh work that
you might want to learn, skills that you
want to have. Like she talks a lot about
uh learning a trade. And so one of the
things that I started to do, I went back
to school and I started to learn
carpentry. And yeah, and I I got a job
working at a place that builds cabinets
and started, you know, practicing my
skills with that just so I can have an
actual practical skill because
Revelation 13 says that there's going to
come a time when no man shall be able to
buy or sell save he that have the mark
of the beast or the number of his name.
And so I want to be able to um have
skills that are pliable in that time
that allow me to help take care of my
family, help take care of my needs
because I believe that time is
in the next few short years, however
many years that are. I don't think it's
far away at all. Um, and I'll just say
the other thing I've been doing is, um,
doing a lot more outreach and ministry.
And so, you know, giving my testimony
places like this, traveling to churches,
uh, and I started, you know, I had an
Instagram following at when I finished
acting. It was, you know, 130,000 or
something like that. And I was just
going to shut it down. I had never
actually run it. I had gotten my sister
to run it because I didn't want to be
too close to people. uh that I didn't
know and have, you know, issues. But um
but when I retired, um I was like,
"Okay, should I just cancel it?" And I
was praying about it. We had an all
night prayer at my church. And I got I
got home and uh the quarterly uh which
is a Bible study um was on my table and
God just put it on my heart, you know,
start reading the quarterly on your on
the live on Instagram. And so that's how
I started. I named uh the the lives. I
called them the last generation live.
And uh so we started doing quarterly
studies and um current events um because
there was things in Matthew 24 and in
Revelation that were that God had put on
my heart that were either going to
happen quickly or had had been
happening. And so when we saw the things
like the earthquake in Turkey and I was
like, you know what, I should talk to
people about these things because it
says that there's going to be
earthquakes in diverse places. It says
that there's going to be pestilence. It
like which we saw in CO. It says that
there's going to be um wars and rumors
of wars and and civil wars and all these
things which we're seeing. And so I
started talking about those current
events
on the live and then doing studies and
and um and so and then we started having
certain guests and things like that. So
at some point I might, you know, pull
one of you guys and hopefully you'd be
willing. But um but yeah, it's it's uh
it's on my Instagram um uh there Eli
Goreay.
Uh and um yeah, it's just that's what
I've been doing as far as that just
traveling and trying to get the message
out there.
Okay. So, as we wrap up here, I'll pose
the question this way. You're an actor
turned carpenter.
Are you just as fulfilled in this life
as you were in the past? I would say
it's so amazing that you asked that
because I wondered that you know I I was
never the money thing was more because I
knew I could take care of my family. the
fame thing was not that important to me.
And people would often ask me even when
I was an actor like, "Do you think
you're, you know, my buddy had a term a
lifer?" Meaning like you're gonna be an
actor for the rest of your life. And I
was always like, "No, I'm not a lifer.
I'm going to do something else for
sure." But I just didn't know what.
But it fulfilled me because of what I
learned when I worked with Ryan. The
craft, the the be ability to see a
process and to bring something to
fruition was
it's a powerful feeling. And when you
start to get good at it, it's a very
powerful feeling. And I remember there's
a story in the Bible of that uh I think
it was a a woman, no it was a man who
who people came to him and he did
miracles. He did false miracles under
under uh by Satan's power,
Simon.
And then and then he saw that they were
able to do miracles under Jesus' power.
He said, "I'll pay you for that." And
you know, they said, "No, no, no, you
can't pay us for that." And then he
followed them, right? And so
I think I had learned a craft that had
power. It had power. I saw it. I saw how
the impact it had on people, on fans, on
people that would see it, people I went
to high school with, and you know, just
everybody, you know what I mean? But
then when I learned this truth and I
learned this beautiful message and I saw
all the connections of like, wow, this
really is a great controversy. We really
are in the last days and Jesus really is
coming soon.
It it gave me a different fulfillment
that was even greater that I never could
have imagined. and doing ministry
um has I'm s I'm surprised but but it
really is fulfilling and more so than
the other thing um but I but only thing
I will say is that I still do get
um inklings not to go back to the
industry but creative ideas will come to
me and I'll say oh man I know like just
the other day I was like man that's a
great concept for a show I already know
who would produce it I know who would
shoot it I already know that I could get
this person to sell it and I'm like No,
no, that's that's the past.
Okay.
You know. Yeah. I'm like that's that
doesn't, you know, and it's not anything
even like immoral stuff, but it's like
that is their system and it's a lie
and I'm not going to be in that system,
you know, and I'm grateful because God
will give me other inspirations, you
know. He'll give me a sermon
or he'll give me I'll be walking and
I'll see something happen in the news
and I'll say, "Oh, that's that's in
spirit of prophecy. I can talk about
that tonight and show the people the
connection of,
you know, this and this. So
God, you can, you know, there's two
sources of inspiration as human beings.
There's Satan can inspire people. He
gives people all kinds of abilities and
and influence and money and all kinds of
different things, right? You look at any
major musical artists out there, they're
those are not they're very creative, but
that's not coming from God, right? And
God can inspire you.
Absolutely. I mean, he gave the talent,
didn't he? He gives you the talent and
he and he can make the most of it for
the for the I think the thing that's the
most valuable to me now is just seeing
souls saved.
Amen.
Just seeing souls won. Seeing people get
that message. The same, you know, the
same thing that all of us have had that
moment where we realize, oh man, this is
real and there's a real heaven. There's
a real hell. And I want to be with
Jesus, you know. And when you see other
people when it when it when it drops and
they see it and they know it's true and
then they start going with it,
there's nothing like that. There's
nothing like that.
I I I think it's just really neat and
powerful that,
you know, Jesus was able to pull you out
of something before you got in a little
bit too far. You know, because you were
pretty far already making the big bucks
and all that kind of stuff. But
man, that is powerful. And I I just
really hope that people who hear this
message will take away that Jesus is
coming very soon.
Mhm.
We see it all around us. Just the signs
of the times. What is it? Matthew 24, I
believe.
Um that he's coming and and you know,
like I've been coming to this conviction
for myself,
having in a church, been in church this
long, having been a Christian this long,
I need a change. You know, I need to get
my act together. I need to spend more
time with the Lord. Not making it
righteous by by my own acts, salvation
through my own acts and works, but
through Jesus, but still to be like,
Lord,
I I need you, you know, and I want to
have more of you because
um because you're coming soon. And I
really hope that when people hear your
story that they're going to want the
same thing because, you know, Satan
offered the whole world to Jesus.
Yeah. and he didn't take it.
And I can see that a lot of celebrities
have taken it. And praise the Lord that
you decide to follow Jesus and say, "No,
and I'd rather surrender all of that and
follow Jesus."
It's almost like the devil's offering
the exact opposite of what Jesus
offered. He says, "Look, if you leave
houses, lands, mother, father, he says,
I will repay you how much?"
100fold.
100fold. Do you know how much that is?
Like we can't even fathom that, right? M
and and he's just like, "Look, God is a
very fair God. He knows like you have
these passions and you have these these
gifts, but it's so easy. The devil says,
"No, I bend it for you and you'll get
the glory." And it's like, if you just
learn how to take what God has given you
and point the glory to him. I mean, you
will be satisfied when you get to heaven
and people come up to you and say, "I'm
only here in heaven because of something
that you or you or you did." That is
something I don't think money can buy.
Yep.
Well, thank you so much, Eli, for being
here with us.
Thank you
for sharing your story. This was an
amazing conversation and we hope you
were blessed as well. If you'd like to
get in contact with Eli or maybe watch
any of the videos that he's posting,
those details will be in the description
of this video. If you'd like to learn
more about Little Light Studios, watch
some of the documentaries that we have
produced. You can go to
littlelightstudios.tv.
All the information is on that site.
Thank you so much for watching. We pray
that you have a blessed weekend. We're
here on YouTube Live every Friday at
noon. So, please subscribe so you don't
miss an episode. Bye-bye.
[Music]
Every day is an opportunity to show
kindness to the world.
Every day is an opportunity to do
something that lets someone know you're
thinking of them.
Thank you.
Every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return.
[Music]
Every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them.
Every day is an opportunity
to do one small thing
to show someone you care.
to make the world a better place.
If you're looking for good, wholesome
educational content for your children,
subscribe to our new channel, Little
Light Kids.
[Music]